carla sospechaba que cuando las personas
se ejercitan más tiempo la temperatura
de su cuerpo cambia aleatoriamente
asignó a unas personas para que se
ejercitarán durante 30 o 60 minutos
después midió sus temperaturas las 18
personas que se ejercitaron durante 30
minutos tuvieron una temperatura media
de 38.3 grados celsius con una
desviación estándar de 0.27 grados
celsius esta es una desviación estándar
muestral para una muestra de 18 personas
las 24 personas que se ejercitaron
durante 60 minutos tuvieron una
temperatura media de 38.9 grados celsius
con una desviación estándar de 0.29
grados celsius supón que se satisfacen
las condiciones para la inferencia y que
carla usará los grados de libertad
conservadores de la muestra de menor
tamaño cuál de las siguientes opciones
es un intervalo de confianza
del 90% para la diferencia en la
temperatura corporal media después de
ejercitarse para las dos cantidades de
tiempo aus en el vídeo y vean si pueden
resolverlo resolvamos el problema juntos
en vídeos anteriores ya habíamos hablado
de la forma general del intervalo de
confianza es decir del intervalo t que
es el que usaremos porque estamos
trabajando con medias y la diferencia en
medias así que nuestro intervalo t
tendrá la siguiente forma la diferencia
entre las medias muestrales esto puede
ser la media muestral para el grupo de
los 60 minutos menos la media muestral
para el grupo de los 30 minutos más o
menos el valor de crítico multiplicado
por la estimación de la distribución
muestral de la diferencia de las medias
muestrales y eso será dejaré suficiente
espacio la desviación estándar muestra
del grupo de 60 minutos al cuadrado
el tamaño de la muestra de ese grupo de
60 minutos más la desviación estándar
muestral del grupo de 30 minutos al
cuadrado entre el tamaño de la muestra
del grupo de 30 minutos entonces
nosotros podemos encontrar todas estas
cosas esto es igual a la media muestral
del grupo de 60 minutos que es 38.9 38.9
menos la media muestral del grupo de 30
minutos que es 38.3 más o menos el valor
de crítico pero como encontramos eso
bueno podemos usar el intervalo o nivel
de confianza del 90 por ciento que es lo
que nos interesa pero si buscamos estos
valores en una tabla t también
necesitamos conocer los grados de
libertad y aquí nos dice que carla usará
los grados de libertad conservadores
eso significa que ella verá el tamaño de
cada una de las muestras una tiene un
tamaño de muestra de edición
y la otra de 24 y usará el valor que sea
más pequeño menos 1 y como grados de
libertad usará el valor que sea más
pequeño menos 1 en este caso 18 es más
pequeño que 24 así que los grados de
libertad en esta situación son 18 menos
1 es decir 17 entonces si usamos esto y
esto podemos buscar el valor en una
tabla de nuestro nivel de confianza es
del 90% y nuestros grados de libertad
son 17 entonces si nos movemos sobre
esta fila y el nivel de confianza del 90
por ciento que corresponde a esta
columna obtenemos que el valor de
crítico es de 1.74 si regresamos esto es
igual a más menos 1.74 por la raíz
cuadrada de cuál es la desviación
estándar muestral para el grupo de 60
minutos
aquí nos lo dieron 0.29 y eso al
cuadrado entre el tamaño de la muestra
para el grupo de 60 minutos vamos a ver
aquí nos dicen que 24 personas se
ejercitaron durante 60 minutos así que
entre 24 más la desviación estándar para
el grupo de 30 minutos que es 0.27 al
cuadrado entre el tamaño de la muestra
para el grupo de 30 minutos que
corresponde a 18 y hemos terminado
analicemos las opciones vamos a ver
todas tienen la primera parte igual
porque quizá esa es la parte más directa
38.9 menos 38.3 después tenemos más o
menos 1.74 así que estas dos opciones
están bien y ya podemos cancelar estas
dos opciones porque tienen un valor de
crítico diferente y después tenemos 0.29
al cuadrado entre 24 más
punto 27 al cuadrado entre 18 esta es la
mejor opción porque aquí tenemos
invertidos estos valores pusieron el
tamaño de la muestra para el grupo de 30
minutos con la desviación estándar
muestral del grupo de 60 minutos y eso
no es correcto por lo tanto nuestra
mejor opción es la opción a nos vemos en
otro vídeo